i'm darren schmitz with vmware and in
this second video of the series i'll be
showing the initial setup of the vsu
replication and site recovery manager
appliances
more specifically the next steps are
performing the vcenter registrations and
initial site pairing
to begin we open our web browser to the
virtual appliance management interface
for the vsphere replication machine and
click to open the appliance management
login page
once logged in the first thing we need
to do is click to configure the
appliance
this process registers the replication
appliance with the google cloud vmware
engine vcenter instance and installs the
vsphere replication extension
on the first screen of the wizard we
provide the vcenter login information
making sure to use the solution user
account we prepared in the previous
video this is because the cloud owner
account does not have the required
privileges to complete these tasks
following through the steps we provide
the site name an administrator email and
select the local host address before
clicking next
after a quick review of the information
we click finish to start the appliance
registering itself with vcenter
once this process is finished we can
move along to do the same process with
the srm appliance
from the virtual appliance management
interface for srm we once again click on
the button to open the appliance
management login page
once logged in we click on the configure
appliance button to begin the srm
registration wizard
since this appliance is also located at
site 1 we can provide the same vcenter
information used with the vsphere
replication appliance
after completing all the steps we once
again review the information and click
finish
once this process completes we will have
registered both appliances at site 1
with their respective vcenter server
from here we need to complete the same
process with the vsphere replication and
site recovery manager appliances at site
2.
for the sake of time this will not be
shown in this video
we now can return to the initial srm
website but this time we click to launch
to the site recovery login page
remember that it is important to log in
using the solution user account because
this account has been granted the
elevated privileges needed to carry out
the vsphere replication and srm tasks
next we can click to create a new site
pair
this will connect site 1 to site 2 so
they can communicate bi-directionally
the pair type is already set to a
different sso domain so we can proceed
to find the site 2 vcenter server we
input the fqdn and solution user account
for the secondary site then click the
find button
after selecting the server we move along
to the services screen where we are
offered to pair both replication and srm
at the same time
after approving both certificate thumb
prints one for each appliance we can
click on finish to get the pairing
started
in a moment or two the pairing will
complete
and the new site pair will appear
now that everything is registered with
fee center
check out the next video in the series
to learn about configuring the site
recovery manager site pair mappings and
advanced settings
to learn more about google cloud vmware
engine visit our site at
cloud.google.com vmware dash engine
[Music]
[Applause]
you